Jason is with us in Minnesota hi Jason
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey how
you doing better than I deserve what's
up okay so and well I my wife and I farm
in well we work farm and we are farming
this year but uh we only had a little
obviously the farm economy's bad and
everything has that for last few years
and we kind of got upside down and we're
looking at like one I know we sold some
properties now we're looking at about
one and a half million in debt right now
what are you doing for a living I wonder
not well we're struggling through
farming oh you're so far you're still
farming okay yeah yeah well kinda yeah
but uh so but five hundred thousand
that's capital gains cuz we sold some
farms and we have a little bit of
property left to sell which would be
about 2.2 million or so in that area and
my question is is you know would it be
better for us to file bankruptcy with
debt or or sell the properties and
everything and then just paid off and we
would have you know we've met maybe you
know five hundred thousand or if we
filed bankruptcy we'd be somewhere
around 1.2 capital gains taxes are not
bankrupt a bull well what's I examining
there's still about a million that's
that's dead that's not capital gain and
it's not on is it not secured by the
land no it's not you have a big unit you
have a million an unsecured debt correct
was it on equipment no it some of it
it's just mainly all your influence and
then uh
credit card debt other other debts that
are you know out there well I mean
you'll have a million in credit card
debt what kind of crow what kind of what
is the million well you know inputs
which would be your chemical companies
and see and all that and then also your
credit card debt is some of it you have
other just other bills or debts houses
and stuff like that do it okay well
anything that has a lien against it
you're either going to keep the debt or
you're going to give up the item correct
so if there's a lien against a piece of
ground there's a lien against a house
as well and oh you know the land stayed
off all the equipment's all scot-free
there's nothing there's nothing there as
far as liens or anything on the unit
stuff yeah but the problem is you can't
have a million dollars in an land
paid for and walk away from a half a
million dollars in debt in bankruptcy
they're gonna the trustees gonna force
you to sell the land to pay your debts
okay yeah that's what I was wondering
that their own forces to sell everything
and then we should cover it up which
means none of our other possibility is
there's a there's a that's a chapter 7
bankruptcy which is a typical bankruptcy
there's a chapter 11 which is a
reorganization which for instance hurts
just filed chapter 11 bankruptcy and
they'll wipe off some of the debt and
restart without all the debt and some of
the you know some of their bond debt and
other things and then they'll reopen or
they'll continue to operate under
Chapter 11 there is a farm bankruptcy
called a chapter 12 and it has some very
unusually good stipulations in it for
you and so you would want to get an
advice from an attorney on exactly your
situation what would occur in a chapter
12
hello chapter 12 would mean we have to
continue farming though and continuing
farming is not part of the equation
okay so you're walking away and gonna
start in the rear right okay so if you
sell all your land how much money would
you have well it would net us about 2.2
and then we all like 1.5 total okay so
you'd walk away with seven or thousand
dollars right you have a seven or
thousand dollar you ever saw seven or
eight thousand dollars net worth
correct okay there is not a form of
bankruptcy that's going to allow you to
not pay those debts and put the entire
proceeds from the land in your pocket
right so you're seven or thousand-dollar
net worth one way or the other is what
you're going to walk from walk away from
this with even in a bankruptcy right
said put in there's no point in even
Colin Baker exactly exactly I would just
sell the land and what I might do is go
back to some of those inputs and since
those are unsecured creditors I might
negotiate with them and
guys all right I'm gonna write you a
check and I'm gonna have to sell my farm
and liquidate everything in order to pay
you and in order to do that you're gonna
give me a deal how much off right and we
rent we've been in some of that now and
they're not real they really don't care
that much it seems like you know they
still want their you still want their
regular money I mean you know worst case
scenario you know and I'm not suggesting
you do this but they you could get their
attention if you chose to do it this way
you sell the land put all the money in a
bank don't pay them and when they don't
get paid for a while then they may
soften up a little bit but if you want
to work with them if you want just write
them a check you're still gonna walk
away with seven or thousand you owe the
money you borrowed the money it'd be the
right thing to do so I think if I'm
you're done with farming you're throwing
up your hands you're going to something
else right correct correct
and you got a seven or thousand-dollar
net worth that's pretty good yep that's
pretty good what type of farming were
you doing sorry this crop okay all right
yeah corn and bean corn and beans all
right and then just the the market just
this last a little bit with Cova just
took it took the last little bit of fun
out of it well yeah that mean last few
years have been kind of rough up and
down you know the markets fed up and you
know you been down he's been he's been a
down turn for the last three or four
years yeah and it's unbelievably hard
work yeah well it is there's a lot of
work I mean you never you never quit
working yeah you're never done yes all
right man I'm sorry but you're good the
good news is you're coming out of this
with some net worth and you can start
something else and you got a whole new
chapter right that's right
all right bro you know what help thank
you you call me anytime I can help I'm
sorry you guys are going through that
it's heartbreaking so you're dirt but um
I think it's where you are I don't
disagree with you
you can double-check my advice with a
bankruptcy attorney but I'm right
I'm not an attorney so you wouldn't want
to get legal advice from somebody
technically other than me but what I've
told you is correct so check it out and
verify that in a 12 you're not you're
not getting away with that debt not with
that net worth huh I'm sorry
Wow what a mess